hello thank you for joining us today for
the first webinar in our data science
series defining the multi-paradigm data
science workflow we are so pleased to
welcome today's presenters sweet white
from our public relations team and a
Brita Chakravarthi of Wolfram u suite
we'll begin today's webinar by sharing
five things you need to know about
multi-paradigm data science
communicating Wolfram's vision for
harnessing computation to take data
science to new levels of analysis and
understanding next a breeder will dive
into specifics by working through the
data pipeline with the use of a
practical real-world example by the time
we close today's session we plan to
share many online resources and links
with you and make a convincing case how
Wolfram technologies can help you take a
multi paradigm approach to data science
my name is Jaime Peterson technical
programs manager with Wolfram research
and I'll be your online host for this
data science webinar series I'm joined
by several of my Wolfram colleagues
behind the scenes to respond to your
typed questions during the webinar and
help point you to the resources you need
feel free to submit your questions using
the control panel on the right side of
your screen you can resize the windows
to customize your webinar experience
we've had good success with Firefox and
Chrome browsers so if you experience any
problems with the screen or audio
streaming you might want to try logging
in with a different browser today's
webinar is a great opportunity for you
to learn more about the various stages
of a data science workflow from
importing data to machine learning
exploring analysis to final
visualizations the presentation
notebooks will be available for you to
download at the end of the webinar and
they can be useful resources for you to
build your skills with the Wolfram
language well before I pass the
microphone to sweet I'm going to share a
quick poll question asking about your
motivation for participating in today's
webinar when the poll question appears
on your screen please select your
response and we'll share the answers
after everyone has a chance to respond
thanks again for joining us our first
presentation is coming up next
okay it looks like we have about 31% of
people that used the Wolfram language
and are interested in data science and
about the same people that use data
science and are interested in Wolfram
language and 39% at I am just interested
in learning new things and we hope that
you will learn new things in our webinar
today
my name is Swede white and I work in
public relations here at Wolfram
research and before we get started with
a breda I'm gonna go through five things
you need to know about multi-paradigm
data science and what it means so let's
go ahead and get started so I'm gonna go
over five key points here basically
harnessing the full power of computation
leading your processes with questions
rather than techniques utilizing fully
customizable reporting and taking
advantage of natural language
understanding along with using multiple
types of data and computational tools
and so on each slide of these I'm gonna
have resources here at the bottom and
this notebook will be available to you
after the webinar in so you can check
out these various resources so first
harnessing the full power of computation
what do we mean by that well you may
think of data science often rooted in
statistical analysis hypothesis testing
regressions t-test detests things of
that nature but as data have become more
complex as we move in into 2018 with new
types of data and new techniques being
developed constantly the type of
computation that you need to analyze
that data must be cutting-edge and must
be able to handle different types of
data with different methods like machine
learning signal processing computer
vision and neural networks so by
harnessing the full power of computation
your tools should be able to select
algorithms automatically for things like
classification and prediction also
bringing the advantage of pre trained
neural nets to your data and also
automating as much as possible including
filling in missing data with imputation
so down here in the resources section
there's a talk here from Etienne Barnard
in our advanced resource group that he
gave in Prague about using symbolic
neural networks and automated machine
learning and there's a downloadable
notebook with that link to get started
with that so a process led by questions
rather than techniques what do we mean
by that well using automated machine
learning and natural
language queries and triggered reporting
is going to free up your process to ask
better questions of your data rather
than being hung up on methods you'll be
able to take tools and use what works
best and be able to ask better questions
to get to better solutions also
utilizing super functions in the Wolfram
language saves development time and you
don't necessarily have to be an expert
in machine learning or statistics to
utilize these tools for example
automatically determining optimal
algorithms for a particular task is
something you can do in the Wolfram
language with just one function you can
also take advantage of knowledge based
programming with curated expert
knowledge so in our Wolfram knowledge
base we have lots of domain expertise
built in that's curated by experts in
Life Sciences engineering extensive geo
computation words and languages and then
our algorithm base is quite extensive as
well we have over 5,000 functions built
into the Wolfram language that are easy
to use fully customizable reporting is
very important in communicating your
results from your data science project
by using the Wolfram language you can
utilize deployment to public or private
clouds using dynamic content you can
also build instant api's to update
reports for a wide variety of interfaces
with real-time data streams and deliver
your results from models and analysis
directly to end-users so some use cases
include direct to client data analytics
through a variety of platforms including
mobile and web also rapidly deploying
microservices and central centralized
computing and reporting with cloud
products natural language understanding
is something that sometimes seems
difficult to implement but with Wolfram
language you can take linguistic
programming and use reform in but to get
to an answer you want you can also build
custom grammars for customized natural
language processing applications so what
that means is you can take your own data
and have it work something like Wolfram
Alpha so with your own data you can have
a free-form input and get customized
reports return what this means is you're
democratizing access to data and access
to these tools so that anyone from the C
suite to the sales team or the day
scientists can ask freeform questions
and get results multiple types of data
and computation are becoming more and
more important in data science
real-world data is indeed messy and
requires a system that can process model
and visualize it in an automated way
especially as more and more data is
being generated and data streams are
becoming faster and faster and with
increasing amounts of data what the
Wolfram language offers is a unified
framework for data wrangling
pre-processing visualization modeling
and reporting so you're not switching
between languages applications or
different packages you're not having to
access or call many different types of
libraries to get the job done you can
also access built-in api's and the
Wolfram language and also external
services and databases and utilize a
system with support for hundreds of
types of data so in conclusion the five
things that you should take away from
multi-paradigm data science is
harnessing the full power of computation
leading your process with questions
rather than techniques utilizing fully
customizable reporting and taking
advantage of natural language
understanding and using multiple types
of data and computational tools all in
one framework you can easily achieve all
this and more and unified data science
workflow and we're going to learn how to
do that in detail right up next
thanks weed I've put up a new poll
question that we are asking about your
use of machine learning and then we'll
have a Brita Chakravarthi giving us her
pipeline presentation following that
all right so we see that some of you 16%
do use pre-built models to train your
data 24% work on building your own
custom models about 48 person use
traditional methods regression models
and other classifiers and so on about
16% are into deep learning and 42% a
little less than half do not use machine
learning great we we hope we have a
little bit for everyone but especially
for the beginners we hope we can give
you a sort of an idea how the Wolfram
technology can be used in this new
multi-paradigm approach to data science
what I hope to bring to you today are
two quick examples through which I can
show how you can build up a workflow to
do your to do that it the kind of data
science you want to so let's get started
now in the car the outline for my talk
today let me quickly share that first I
just wanted quickly show our view of the
multi-paradigm data science we did a
great job of highlighting our five
important points the way we see it and
then I'm quickly going to dive into an
example of a workflow I also want to
touch base on how you can actually
quickly go from playing around with
codons in a scratch pad to shareable
analysis with the help of our technology
and finally I want to bring up the case
for a data science pipeline why you
should even think about it or how it can
be helpful in your project so currently
we see all these nice infographics about
data science you know all the stuff that
you need you need mathematics and
statistics or machine learning are
things like that sometimes I find it a
little intimidating and that's just
personal experience that oh my goodness
I mean all this stuff I don't know much
of it how do I get into data science or
you know I like this more fun
from traffic I found which you know I
didn't even know something like data
artistry existed but you know that's a
nice way of putting things I can be a
data artist while I'm doing data science
or you know data surfing data wrangling
data mining and all these different ways
of approaching data science and so we
again we are bringing to you our
approach and multi-paradigm data science
and you know we welcome you to check out
our website on this but like let's leave
all that aside let's just dive into some
data science and work with some data and
see how we can build this up so let's
push out a quick poll I want to do a
tweet analysis we that's very common
nowadays you know you have a tweet
stream and you want to do some basic
analysis for your social media so we're
going to push out a quick poll and I'm
going to see what sort of a keyword you
might be interested in to do this tweet
analysis so we can look for tweets about
the World Cup or the Avengers infinity
war or you know the S&P 500 index or we
can look for wolf line tweets about the
Wolfram language let's see who wins
all right so pushing out the results it
seems like World Cup was a clear winner
it got about 35% of the votes and so
it's interesting because I prepared my
presentation with the World Cup keyword
and I'm very happy like the majority of
you agreed with me so let's let's get
started I'm going to open up here I'm
going to start sharing my screen again
okay and I'm going to open up a new
notebook and just write out some code
and then we can work through this
together okay
so
one word of caution is that you know for
some of you this might be a new
programming language so don't get lost
in the you know the details of the code
try to follow along and of course I'll
make all this available so you know you
can always play around with it at the
end so just just try to follow along
what the the intention the idea behind
what we are trying to do so I'm going to
get started by connecting to Twitter and
I have already tried this before for
those of you who would be doing it for
the first time the program quickly takes
you to your browser to allow you to
authenticate the Wolfram language to
connect to your Twitter account and once
you are done with that you can actually
start interacting with Twitter and get
your data from there so let's let's
start as we thought we'll work with the
keyword woke up and so I've said the key
word here and then now I'm going to get
the tweets and just for the purpose of
this example I'm going to restrict my
language to English because I want to do
some sort of sentiment analysis and
right now our classifier worse with on
the English language text for sentiment
analysis this is a inbuilt classifier I
mean if you you are welcome to train
your own classifier on other languages
that that works fine but just for this
example we are going to use a pre-built
model and so I'm going to restrict to
English and so let's see if I can get
the tweets here and these are the tweets
that I have so first thing what can we
do let's do a timeline of the tweets so
let's go down here and I'm going to do a
tweet timeline basically I'm doing a
histogram of the times at which the
tweets went out so I think I got 500
tweets and so you see between 10 and 11
there was a rise and then a drop and so
you can see how this might be useful if
you're trying to follow your social
media the the social media analytics for
your company or you know just for the
fun of it you for trying to follow
tweets on something you want to see
how people are tweeting about a
particular topic is there some insight
you can derive from the pattern in
according to time
another very basic analysis we can look
at you know favorites like likes and
then maybe rich retweets so let's do a
quick histogram of favorites so you know
most of the tweets they were not like
too many times but there are these
outliers here the one that was retweeted
about 200 tanks from this 500 tweets
that we got we downloaded let's also
look at I'm sorry this was just a
favorite count the one of the tweets was
like more than 200 times now here are
the retweets okay so again we see that
you know most of the tweets are
retweeted a couple of times but you know
a couple of hundred times but then there
are some tweets that have been retweeted
a lot more number of times now finally
let's go get to the interesting part and
I'm just going to work with 50 of the
random samples from the data that I got
so I'm going to just take 50 of these
tweets and then I'm going to try and do
some sentiment analysis we have the
classify function in the Wolfram
language and there is a prebuilt
classifier
it is named sentiment and you can use it
like this and it should tell me whether
the language of the the text of the
tweet whether it was neutral positive or
negative and once I have that I can also
you know visually present it or just
let's summarize it quickly just lets
take a look at the numbers so of the 50
that I got your 31 neutral and 20 were
positive I didn't uh-huh so there were
no negative tweets apparently just for
this case so once I have that
information I can also visualize it
quickly so I get a pie chart this is not
that interesting the last time I did it
I did get some negative tweets so it was
a little more interesting to see you
know the comparison of the
Stevan the negative tweets okay
so now that I have shown you this and we
did this with the World Cup like right I
want to show you how easy it is to just
you know switch over to whatever it is
that you would like to do whatever other
keyword that you would like to pick and
do a similar analysis on so the
reproducibility of your analysis so you
know S&P 500 was the second most fold or
voted for keyword so I can switch to
that and let's see if I can get about a
thousand tweets for that I'm using the
you know the I'm sorry the the ticker
symbol for S&P 500 and here what I've
done is I have actually the the analysis
that we are doing just before I've just
you know redone it I know there's a
bunch of code but alright all I want to
show you is that it's the same analysis
I've just prettied it up so most of the
code here is you know to make it look
nicer you know square and so make the
picture square of the right size and
then use a certain kind of plot team and
that stuff and the reason is because I
want to create an infographic out of it
so I'm going to run this and then I'm
going to create the infographic here to
show you like you know how easy it is to
quickly create something like this to
share your report and the next thing I
want to show you is this I created on
the fly right but what if you have to
create this over and over again so in
that case you can set up automated
reports so let me show you the template
of a report that I have created so this
is a special notebook this is a template
notebook and what you can do in template
notebooks is that you can have
placeholders so for example here I have
the keyword placeholders and so I can
run this template
by supplying it a keyword over and over
again and it will generate the same sort
of report and I can change the keyword
to whatever it is and so the code to do
that is here okay so you see I'm just
getting the template notebook the first
part of the code here is that I'm
getting the template notebook and the
second part of the code is where I'm
setting the keyword okay so this time
I'm going to do it for Wolfram language
and I go ahead and do that and let's see
what kind of an analysis we get back for
the Wolfram language now this report I
this is the this is the quick the quick
report I generated I apologize for the
little typo here i forgot to use the the
placeholder there instead of you know
actually hard coding the keyword but
anyway you get the idea and what i
wanted to point out is that here I used
a generate document to do this once I
can deploy a scheduled test to the cloud
and I can have make sure that this
report is automatically generated you
know for example every day at five
o'clock and then you know I can have it
set so that it is sent to specific
people who need to look at that report
so the intention of showing this example
was that we did some data science here
we didn't stop to worry about what sort
of you know modeling we were going to
use whether we're going to use machine
learning or statistics or some you know
we didn't get into the heavy details we
got some data we played around with it
we did some basic analysis we prepared
it prepared our results to share with
other people and this is really the
multi-paradigm approach to data science
that we are suggesting that you know you
can do a whole lot of different things
and you can automate it if you don't
like you know use
the pre-built sentiment classifier we
have you can train your own and we have
the framework and the code available for
that so let's let's so this was very you
know quick and expiratory let's do a
little more you know a little more
linearized approach to how to analyze
some more data so moving on I'm gonna
see if there could you make that
notebook up at 150 maybe that might help
see some of those details the one that's
there right now right okay I have it at
150 I'm moving to 200 is this better
yeah that looks better thanks okay and
what I am also going to do is I'm going
to share this notebook with you in a
little bit actually I think I can share
it with you right now if you want to
look at it I was going to keep this up
my sleeve for later to show you how easy
it is to do this in the Wolfram language
but I'll go ahead and share it with you
right now so let me see I'm gonna copy
the hyperlink and I am going to post it
on the chat window okay and so you
should be able to download the notebook
from there or you know open it up in
cloud and play around with it if you
want but let's move on to my next
example we are going to work with some
real estate data so I was able to find
this publicly available real estate data
on the rolling sales of homes in New
York and the data is available for like
five different boroughs so let's let's
just take a quick poll and decide which
follow the current audience likes today
and then we can go ahead and work on
that so Jamie or Cassidy if you could
push out the poll I have data for
Manhattan Bronx Brooklyn Queens and
Staten Island
and I will try to show you to work walk
through the workflow with you today on
one of those data sets okay
we're closing the polls so we have a
winner Manhattan so let me try to grab
some data on Manhattan and then we can
get going so here is my screen so I'm
going to get the data from this URL here
and let's see what our import function
allows you to do is actually check out
what is available from this URL so I can
see that
okay that's there I can see from the URL
it's an XLS file so I can also see what
what can I get from this I can get the
data I can get it as the data set which
is our data structures in the Wolfram
language - nicely organized your
information I can get it as formatted
data formulas images and shades I'm just
going to go with basic data and I know
in most excel sheets you usually have
the data on the first sheet so I'm going
to go ahead and actually just grab the
first first sheet from this XLS and so
this is the raw data here and you know
every time we get some raw data we like
to take a peek into it so let's see the
first 10 lines of the raw data so we
have some information here about the
file here in a neighborhood names and
descriptive data and so on and here we
see we actually have what looks like the
feature names right and then I think the
real data starts from here right
but I hate that that's not always enough
it's always good to see what's at the
end of your data - and that's what we
are going to do here and as a lot of you
might have suspected this is an Excel is
right so the excel sheets have lots of
blank rows and I can see them right here
a good number of blank rows so now that
we have gotten our data so this is this
is what a lot of you often do and this
is what the phase where we call it
something like data import or data
acquisition something like that so we
just be we got the data here and now we
see there might be some problems with
the data so what we do in this phase is
something that's often called data
cleaning so let's go ahead and do some
data cleaning let's start out by looking
at the length of the raw data here my
colleagues are answering your questions
right now but if there are some
questions we can't get to we'll do a we
we will have some time at the end of the
presentation I'd be happy to take
questions then as well so please be
patient if we cannot get to your
question right now we'll definitely try
to get to it at the end of the
presentation okay so an easy thing to do
I saw all those empty rows right so an
easy thing to do is to just get rid of
those so I'm going to I have the raw
data and I'm going to get my clean data
out of there at least clean at this step
by just deleting all those empty rows
and now I can look at how many real rows
of data do I have about seventeen
thousand seven hundred and twenty seven
and I also want to get all the features
remember it was there up there in the
fifth row so let's get that here okay
so we have information about the borough
itself but now we got the data we pulled
in the data only for Manhattan so I'm
guessing this will be the same for most
of the rows if not all it should be the
same for all the rows we have
information about neighborhood something
called building class category tax class
at present block Lord easement and you
know a whole bunch of other things I can
see the address which might be of
interest the zip code residential units
commercial units and total units some
square footage you're built which might
be interesting and then of course
there's sale price and sale date those
should definitely be useful one thing I
want to point out you're like a lot of
data scientists or people trying to do
something with data science is that we
do not always have all the expert
information at hand right what does this
really mean and while I had the I was
lucky enough to be able to talk with a
real terrific friend of mine to get an
understanding of what all this is really
about
I want to point out that that's not
always necessary it's good of course
it's very good to have expert in input
but you know sometimes you can just play
around with things and in that
especially in your in cleaning or
exploring data let's not get too hung
about what exactly some of the features
mean so let's see we I'm going to store
the number of features here in a
variable because I'm going to use that
later on so we have 21 different
features now let's see how we can use
them to just visualize this and use it
later on I'm just going to present it
differently so I can now see which
feature is you know which column
actually represents which features so
later on while I work with columns it's
easier for me to figure out what am I
really working with now this can
completely be done in a very different
way as you all probably know there are
more than one ways to do a thing and you
know especially in code many different
ways so I'm not claim
this is the most efficient but to me
this was the most intuitive and that is
why I'm presenting it here we this is
definitely becomes much easier when you
use data sets the Wolfram language data
sets it's it yeah you know that it's
much more organized and then we can
quickly apply functions to rows and
columns with the data sets and
associations so while I'm putting it out
there for today for the purposes of this
particular presentation I'm gonna stick
with lists lists of lists and just work
through it so I want to do a quick
analysis of these features what do I
have in there what type of information
what type of you know do I have strings
do I have numbers do I have something
else are there empty rows or empty
columns are they how many unique values
does each column have and so I've
written this bit of code and then again
don't get lost in the code just try to
follow along what am I trying to do and
I hope the result shows here so here I
have the feature in this this column
here I'm trying to see what type of
feature it is it's so I see it's a real
number here or there is a string and
here is a combination of real numbers
and strings how many different unique
values does that particular column have
so this column has just one unique value
because this is from Manhattan so I
think that that's just the one value for
the Manhattan borough and so probably
for any sort of discriminative analysis
that's not going to be useful because
it's the same for all the samples there
is a neighborhood and it is all almost
entirely strings this this particular
feature it has 39 unique values so
probably there are 39 neighborhoods that
have samples in this particular example
there are other things but things to
worry about are these features where
there seems to be a mix of real and
string so depending on the value the
real features in there you know we have
to figure out why some of them are reals
and why some of the them are strings and
then once you figure that out
probably we want to go in and do some
cleaning there to make sure you know all
are of the same type and otherwise we
can run into problems in further
analysis let's see we have the zip code
as a real number well we could actually
turn it into a real zip code with the
help of Wolfram language and that's
where we we will bring in some of you
know the the extra knowledge base that
is built into the language and that can
become very helpful and augmenting your
data there are other things the Euro
built is also a real number so probably
we want that as some sort of a data
object to help us actually work with
that or maybe just leave it as real you
know just because we have something
available we don't always need to use it
depends on what we want to do with it
later on and then we have the sale price
as a real number but here the sale date
interestingly we have as a data object
so when we were importing the data
Wolfram language was clearly able to
understand ok this is a date and it
immediately converted into converted it
into a data object so we've got some
understanding of what it looks like what
kind of elements are there in this data
but let's actually look at some of some
of the samples itself so I'm gonna pick
out five random samples where possible
for each feature and we're not possible
we just have how many ever we can get
sober oh there's just one unique value
so we just get that one but here are
some five samples of neighborhood and
five samples of the building class
category this looks a little weird which
which makes you you know think maybe we
want to pick this out and paste it and
see what's really going on there and
there's the tax classes we see oh the
you know the ever-present empty string
which you can throw a wrench into all
your analysis so that needs to be taken
care of
we don't want empty strings in there
this feature seems to be pretty useless
it's it's an empty string for all the
rows so we probably want to throw out
that feature and there are other
information we can see here we have
apartment numbers we see
the zip codes residential units
commercial units total units here's
another red flag how can the land square
feet be zero so that's again probably
missing data that we want to take care
of your build tax class at time of sale
and then building class and sale price
and sale eight okay
so let's move on with this we have a
decent idea of the data but we saw that
one the two things we need to watch look
out for there were zeros and there were
missing empty strings which both
probably denote missing data so let's
take a quick look to see how many zeros
and how many missing empty strings did
we have for each feature so we see some
features are pretty clean but then here
we have 111 empty strings for this
particular feature tax class at present
and then we see the zip code has two
zeros in there which is probably again
missing data it should have been a
proper zip code and you can see there
are a whole bunch of zeros here for the
area of the land or the growth the land
square feet gross square feet and then
even missing data for your bills so
these are the things to look out for so
for data cleaning for this particular
data let's just get rid of the empty
strings and the zeros so what I'm going
to do is I'm going to actually string
trim the string values here because we
want to get rid of you know preceding
and following strings from the strings
and now if we do a string string trim
then we can easily get rid of empty
strings so especially for features four
and eight so let's go back here this tax
class present which had 111 empty
strings and eight building class at
present which also had hundred and
eleven empty strings I'm going to go
ahead and remove the empty strings
replace them with the missing object in
the Wolfram language which allows us to
easily represent missing data and for
the other features the ones that are
here feature numbers from 11 to 20 some
in between there I'm going to replace 0
or 0 a point so either it's an integer 0
or a real I'm going to replace it with
missing as well ok so now I'm going to
drop the column 1 and 7 as we had
discussed because we saw column 1 has
the same value actually up here column 1
had just one single value and column 7
didn't have any values at all so let's
go ahead and drop those columns and we
structured the data ok and now let's
look at the dimensions of the data we
still have seventeen thousand seven
hundred and twenty-seven rows but we
only have 19 columns right now and let's
do the same restructuring for the
feature name so that we can use that
usefully later on so now we have
nineteen features instead of twenty one
because we dropped two features so this
is where we did some data cleaning now
that we have a reasonable reasonably
clean data let's actually do some
exploratory analysis okay so this is
where we play around with the variables
and see what they look like so we we are
going to see if there are some samples
where there is no sale price you know we
are working with sale prices of homes we
want to see if there are samples that
there are no sale price no sale price
remember was the last but one column and
hence I'm trying to look for the pattern
where I have you know a wild card
anything and then in the last but one
column I have missing and the last
column I can have anything again and I
have these are my samples with missing
sale prices let's see how many of them I
do
3746 let's lick take a look at what they
look like ok so here the sale price is
missing and some additional data is
missing for these as well so what's
common in all this samples I'm showing
you here the sale price is missing but
let's let's actually try to see what's
going on with this data
I wanted to see when so the the sale
date records when the transaction
happened so apparently for this data
that the transaction happened but the
sale price was not recorded so I did dig
into the website a little bit apparently
if the ownership changes without a real
seal then this sort of these sort of
samples get created where there is a
sale but there is no sale price and so I
wanted to see when these sort of things
are happening now since I have the dates
it was very tempting to do a time line
plot on this unfortunately that took
forever because there's like three
thousand you know two three thousand
sample points here so getting a time
line plot was not that easy but it
eventually happened I'm not going to try
and do it live but I'm going to show you
the result here you see somewhere here
on the 6th of 7th of August there were a
whole bunch of these transactions that
did not have a sale price recorded but
then a transaction had really happened
so during the exploratory analysis phase
all these sort of interesting things can
crop up I can do a similar analysis that
happens much faster is if I do a count
of the sale date and then I can just do
a dateless plot so basically I you know
gather together the all the sales that
are happening transactions that are
happening on a particular sale date and
then I plot it across the dates and so
that same peak I can see here and so you
know if if that
what I want to really know about I can
zoom in there and do further analysis
another quick exploration I can do is I
want to see for these particular
buildings where the same price is
missing what are these particular
buildings looking like so I count the
number of the different types of
buildings that have these transactions
recorded and I take the top 10 I see
these are the top 10 that seem to change
hands without a sale price being
recorded and again this it's boring to
look at numbers so we can always make
pictures out of this sort of information
and so I can visualize it as a pie chart
here and my intention to show you is
this at this expiratory phase that's the
you know the our our stash of algorithms
of functions that we have to offer can
make it really easy to you know walk
through this data and see if we can find
something interesting ok so now let's
actually work with the more interesting
part of the data which is buildings or
transactions that actually did have some
sales price recorded so we are just
going to delete the missing data from
this now and so now we have seen
transactions that have some sale price
recorded about thirteen thirteen
thousand nine hundred and eighty-one
transactions so let's do some
explorations with this so remember we
had the ZIP codes so let's see that was
in one of the columns there let's let's
take a quick look at what were the
features like okay zip code was here
column number nine right so we are going
to get the zip code out and we are going
to actually convert the number the real
numbers that are standing in for the zip
code to actual dip codes here so we have
this interpreter of the type zip code
and when you have the notebook which
I'll be uploading shortly you will be
able to actually work with it and you
can hover over a particulars function
name if you like and you can oh
our documentation about it and here you
see we have documentation about
interpreters and you can see the number
of different interpreter types we have
the usual string numbers and so on but
then we also have other things like URL
email address dates and times I'll leave
it to up to you to go ahead and explore
this so anyway we have the zip codes now
so let's go ahead and quickly see how
many transactions happened in the zip
codes and for that since I have the zip
codes let me show you an example of the
zip code so it's an entity which is a
smarter object so there rather than just
the number representing the zip code
it's now an entity of type zip code and
it has a whole lot of other information
so I can show you what sort of
information it has so I
from you know the flat zip code which
was just a number to more information
about this zip code and one one such
information that's available with this
entity is the geographical location I'm
going to use that in two actually so
this is this is all a whole bunch of
information that I can just get from the
zip code I'm going to use the
geographical location to actually plot
this out in a map and show you which is
color-coded by the number of sales
happening in each zip code so that's
what I did with this your region value
plot so if I am really interested in the
zip codes where the most number of
transactions occur I can zoom in easily
from the my map and work on it okay so
these were some examples and then I have
a whole bunch of other examples too for
exploratory analysis but I don't want to
you know test her patience for a long
let me show you just one other quick
example let's do an analysis of the ages
of the buildings so I'm going to make a
histogram of how all the buildings are
so I'm just going because it was real
I'm just going to subtract it from the
current here and find the age and so you
see I have the number of buildings here
that are just 10 years old 50 years old
100 years old or there's something that
this is interesting I'm not too sure
about that that appears to be 200 years
old but anyways you know that's that's
what exploratory analysis is supposed to
do bring draw your attention to you know
things that stand out okay one more
thing that I can do is I want to see the
total sales on a particular day so I'm
going to group by the group the data
according to the sale date and I'm going
to add up the number of the amount of
sales on that day and I'm going to
create a data plot so on this particular
day there was you know sales upwards of
2.5 billion dollars here so it might
either be there Mike there were a lot of
sales or there might have this been this
huge sale of a building that was that
that
really highly priced so moving on from
exploration let's actually try and do
some modeling what we'll try to do is
predict the home price based on all
these additional features that we've
been saying but before jumping into
modeling we'd like to do something
that's called data pre-processing that
is basically prepare our data to
actually do the modeling so for data
pre-processing once again let's quick
take a quick look at the kind of
features we have ok these were the
features we had so I'm going to
pre-process the data
so basically reformatted restructure it
and prepare it to be a useful input to
the the classifier predict function a
machine learning function that I'm going
to use later on so what I'm going to do
is I'm picking up only the homes that
have sales price more than 5 million
sorry less than 5 million and then I'm
just reformatting this data what I'm
trying to do is you know I want to take
the neighborhood the building class
category the tax class and so on and I'm
going to leave out some of the features
now some of the features remember there
were both real numbers and strings so
that is why I'm going to try and convert
each to string to make sure I have only
string features and don't I don't have a
mix of numbers and strings and then I'm
also going to take care of missing
information and basically just get it
ready to use it for my classifier or
predictor let's take a quick look at
what this now looks like ok not very
different so I have a whole bunch of
features and it points to the sale price
so this is the way I need my data
structured so that I can feed it into a
machine learning algorithm so based on
these features on the Left I'm going to
predict the target value which is the
sale price on the right here okay but
there's just one more step before it you
see I have a mix of features I have
nominal or categorical features which
are names like
the name of the neighborhood financial
Upper Eastside so on and I have numbers
as well here so this is a real number or
here or I think there's the age of the
building somewhere here so I have a mix
of words and numbers right if I just
throw it blindly at my machine learning
model might not do that well so one
thing that I would like to do is convert
these features a little bit into a
useful form so I want to use these the
nominal or categorical features and an
integer vector so basically an integer
code for each nominal or categorical
class so financial probably you will get
see an integer code of one a per
Eastside can get a code of two and so
I'm going from nominal or words to
numbers because it's always easier to
work with numbers okay so now let's
bring in some machine learning now that
our data is ready I am going to break up
this pre-process data set that I have
I'm going to break it up into a training
set and a test set so I have nine
thousand nine hundred fifty two samples
in my training set and let's see how
many I have in my test set okay good and
now I'm going to bring in our built-in
function predict and again you can look
it up in our documentation so what you
basically have to do is give it a
training set and I also give it an
option to use the feature extractor
based on the feature vector that I
created here right so I some of the
features I want them as integer vectors
some I want a standardized vector
because you know these numbers are all
over the place I would rather have them
standardized so that I can actually
compare one feature to another and so
I'm going to go ahead and run this to
let the predict function actually figure
out what sort of an algorithm a machine
learning algorithm would be the best
choice in this case
to be able to predict the sale price of
a home from the information that was
given to it so you can see the progress
indicator right now it's looking at
linear regression and you can see how
the standard deviation is changing
giving us an idea of how it is
performing now it moved on to random
forests and then on to gradient booster
trees it's trying out these different
algorithms under the hood trying to
decide which one is the best and we can
see which one it picks out right now I
think it's going to stick with gradient
boost to trees I did I wanted to
actually let you pick your algorithm but
at this point I think we might be
running a little short on time and so
we'll skip that but you know you should
be able to set if you have your favorite
algorithm for this sort of predictions
you should be able to actually use the
predict function okay sorry about that
what happened here okay let's try that
again
so it might have run into some issues
okay let's just try that again what I
wanted to say is you should be able to
actually set the method here and let's
see we can I'm just going to pick
gradient boosted trees to reduce the
training time so that it's not going to
try all the different methods to pick
and I'm saying just go with gradient
boost to trees and so you can actually
set your own method whether you want
decision trees random forests just plain
linear linear regression and so on and
you can work with predict you can tell
predict to strain a model just with that
algorithm and we'll see if it can go
ahead and
please this is used about 15% of the
training set moved up to 80% and we have
a predictor function that we can use now
too and we can use it on some test data
so remember we had created a test set so
I'm going to use something called
predictor measurements again a built-in
function I'm going to give it this
predictor function that we have trained
on the training data and I'm going to
give it some test data and I'm going to
get some measurements of how well this
model is performing there's a whole
bunch of things we can get out of it but
for today I'm just going to show you the
comparison plot which intuitively shows
how this is you know how the predicted
prices are performing against the
original prices so I can I can sense a
lot of arrows there well this is not the
best model and I understand however I
must point out to you we did you know
the simplest analysis we didn't try any
sort of feature engineering or you know
we didn't didn't really go in there and
clean the data a little better I just
showed you some basic cleaning and so on
so I think we can benefit with a little
more of feature engineering feature
selection feature extraction and maybe
even a reduction in the number of
features because I don't think some of
them might be overlapping in information
so maybe a little bit of dimensionality
reduction all these different things can
help us improve the performance of the
model but for now this is a performance
we have we do have some that fall on the
nice line that we would expect for
perfect predictions but then there are a
whole bunch of these samples all over
the place but I also want to draw your
attention to the fact that how easy this
was to create this visual representation
of the modulus performance it's all
built-in in the language itself in the
machine learning toolbox that we have so
once we are done with this let's see
what else can we do so this this gives
me an understanding that the features as
such they can do a reasonable job on
predicting the price but it needs more
work so what else can I get what other
things can I get from my data here I
asked
there is a friend of mine and he said
you know what we always have to do this
comps analysis for when we are about to
sell a home we compare it with you know
representative homes in the same area
and the the way these listings are
usually set up for the realtor says they
have to go to each individual page and
look at them and then try to figure out
okay is this a reasonable comparison but
machine-learning can make it so much
easier you know so let's see if we had
to share the insight with this realtor
friend of mine what could I do for him
so let's I would just reformat the data
a little differently so I I did I
restructured the data in this way
actually let me just show you a couple
of random samples from there okay so I
have I group the data by neighborhood so
if there was a sale going on in a
neighborhood I put it all together and I
have the information set up so that I
have a whole bunch of features and then
I have the address of that place and and
the price that it was sold for sorry the
address of the place is up till here and
then the price it was sold for okay now
I now that I have this information I am
actually going to try to do some deduce
given a sample I want to figure out five
nearest homes five homes that are
comparable to this building that I'm
looking at the sample I'm looking at so
let's see let's pick up two
neighborhoods
okay remember I had 39 different
neighborhoods here
so there's Washington Heights lower and
Little Italy so what I want to try and
do here then I'm going to pick up a
sample from one of these homes here one
of these neighborhoods here
so let's pick up a home or a building or
a transaction from Washington Heights
lower and I am going to look at five
similar buildings or homes or whatever
from Little Italy and I'm going to see
what they were what was the sale price
of those homes so what I'm going to what
I can do for that is again I have that
problem where I have a combination of
numerical data and nominal data you know
words and phrases text so I do want to
get all that into numbers because with
numbers it's easier to calculate the
distance so you can quickly calculate
mathematically how far a sample point is
from another if you all that you have is
numbers so for that what I'm going to do
is something called feature extraction
again with our built-in functions
feature extraction and I am going to get
all the data from little italy here i'm
going to build up a feature extra
function so what this function will do
when I feed it similar information you
know mix of numbers and text is going to
convert it all into numbers so let's see
let's look at it at play here I'm sorry
okay so now you see all I have is a
bunch of numbers no more words there
right so I have all these numbers that
represent that sample and then I have
the address and the price of that sale
okay so now for comparison where was a
random sample from Washington Heights so
this was our sample from Washington
Heights so what I am going to use is our
nearest function and I'm going to find
the comparisons for this particular
example so Washington Heights and these
feature values it had a sale price of
1.9 million so let's see what comparable
prices we get in the neighborhood Little
Italy five closest buildings for this
particular building here based on its
features so these are the ones we get I
see this address repeated twice which
probably means this has apartments and
so even this one here so probably there
are apartments there you know the same
building but different apartments but
yes this information I have that's great
but one thing that my realtor friend
also mentioned that they love to look at
it on maps so I can get it in there I
have this as a string the address but I
can again use our interpreter and
convert it into a street address here
and then I use our Geographics function
specifically geographic sent to your
marker to actually show this information
that I obtain these comps that I obtain
on the map so the interpreter is
sometimes hits our servers and so might
take a little while and so now I have
nicely laid out on the map the
comparable sales to the sample that I
had picked out there at these addresses
and these were the prices they sold for
okay so that was a quick run-through of
the workflow and what I wanted to point
out
to you right now is that once you've
done this analysis we did it like a
scratch pad right we try different
things we we try to comment as we go on
I made these sections to show what we
were working on and now I can just
collapse these and see that this is
really the workflow we built up we did
it we imported the data we clean the
data we explored it we did some
pre-processing we use machine learning
and then we tried to share the insight
that we get once you have done this
analysis it is very easy to actually
pretty it up a little more you know I
can go into these sections put in some
more text just off the top of my head
you know comment put in comments useful
information pretty up your notebook and
then again what you can do is just go
ahead and share it so I'm going to go
ahead and share this with you if you
want to share your analysis right away
with the rest of the world or there are
other options and I'm going to show that
to you in a moment as when I get the
link to share with you
okay
okay again you can download this
notebook oh and then work with it or
play around with it try other different
things but that's just not the only way
to share the information what I also
want to point out I'm sorry sorry I have
too many open windows here I'm trying to
find out the right information right so
we have a whole other suite of functions
here we have cloud publish that I showed
you right now then there's also cloud
shared cloud apply is if you couch air
would be something you would use if you
wanted to just share your notebook with
coworkers who are working with you on
the analysis and then finally we also
have cloud deploy which is the you know
the top end where you have a product
that you have created that with your
models running on the background and you
want to create a little microsite with
that model running on the background
letting your users interact with your
model and analysis and that would be
something you would use so switching
gears and wrapping up the presentation
today I want to talk about you know this
workflow that we created can also be
termed as a pipeline and so I just want
to wrap up that you know while it's fun
exploring and doing things trying on
different things probably it's helpful
to have you know a general compass
heading to remember that you know the
idea is after all to get from a question
to an actionable insight so you you need
to have that question in mind and how
you're going to get to the actionable
insight so just ending the presentation
today I wanted to point out that we we
have this world of data we are getting
all this information in and we are
trying to use it to the best we best of
our abilities so having in mind that you
know you want to start out the question
and the purpose of data science is
really to get to an actionable insight
so having these two points clearly in
mind helps us get more out of our data
project and so trying to get from this
question to the inside what we need is a
data pipeline which is like the set of
code that handles all the computational
tasks from beginning to end and why do
you need the pipeline because it can
give you ability and reproducibility you
can do the same analysis over and over
again so like you know with a lot of
things in life it's better to have a
planner workflow if you're cooking a
special meal you don't just want to
throw it trow whatever you have in the
pantry into the pot you know you
probably want to get your groceries if
you have fresh vegetables you're
cleaning and prepping them you're
picking the right utensils to grill or
saute or bake or whatever you want and
then finally you also want to probably
garnish and present the meal as best as
you can for the special person you're
cooking for it's kind of the same for
data science you know well you don't
have to do them you have probably your
own workflow but it helps to have you
know keep tabs on certain things that
need to be done and that is what this
pipeline is pointing out to you is that
probably you start out with a question
you get the data and there's something
that you call wrangling so all the plate
that the parts where we got this data
from the excel sheet in our example and
you know we were reformatting it into
the right kind of input for the predict
function or the way we wanted to work
with it when we were finding the closest
comparisons that is data wrangling but
it can also lead on to data cleaning
where we worked with the missing data
taking care of the zeros and the empty
strings and so on and once you are done
with cleaning we did some exploratory
analysis that's where you are trying to
figure out what can you get from this
data really and you then you can go on
to pre-processing now you have an idea
what the data looks like how you need it
for your modeling phase where you do
statistical analysis or machine learning
and often you go back again and go have
multiple iterations of these various
stages of the pipeline until you are
happy with your model and then you're
ready ready to validate it make sure
that it is doing what is supposed to be
doing and once you're happy with that
you are ready to tell your story which
hopefully will lead to an actionable
insights so with that we hope we have
been able to give you some pointers to
how you can use the Wolfram technology
to build your data science workflow and
how you can have a multi paradigm
approach while building this so I'm
going to wrap up the presentation and
move on to questions but we are going to
end with a poll we would like to know
that if you see your workflow in sort of
this pipeline manner where do you
anticipate spending most of your time in
this pipeline okay so one one thing I
definitely want to point out and let's
see if I can share my browser after the
poll is done of course and I'm not sure
if you've seen it in the chat but we
have had a number of questions about
using our Python and Excel with the
Wolfram language yes so we do have
something that's called externally
evaluate that allows that and south with
11:23 that allows you to actually pull
in your existing Python library or our
and and you know incorporate your code
from there into Wolfram language so if
you've already done substantial work
creating things you don't have to throw
it out you can always incorporate it in
but we hope you will also look at some
of the stuff that we have that should
make it you know much easier to do
things in the Wolfram language so yes
interfacing with other technology is
definitely possible so we are sharing
with you the results we see that 13% of
you are actually thinking that you might
be doing a lot of data wrangling 31% of
cleaning that was expected some of you
with exploratory analysis about 26% 29%
expecting to spend time in machine
learning and statistical analysis and
just about one person preparing error
reports but I do want to point out you
know preparing the reports is can be the
most important part of your analysis
like you know you do want to convey the
story and I
we make a great case there we have all
the tools available for creating these
stunning visualizations that you can
actually share easily with the world you
know I was going to point out our
Wolfram how easy it is to share things
on the Wolfram cloud but as I as I try
to bring up my browser suite do you do
you want to share something quickly on
the epc i see there is a question there
has been some questions there and you
had something to share about the
enterprise private cloud would you mind
sharing it live with the audience there
are some use cases that we can look at
with enterprise private cloud look at a
couple of these right now so this one is
pretty interesting to write to client
analytics if you go to this website
right here there is a workflow here
where you connect to external databases
build a qualitative model you have
coding and some instant api's that are
then modeled automatically and then
pushed you a user interface you can run
simulations there so this particular
workflow goes through how this would
work using our private cloud there's
also uh centralized computation and
reporting another use case right here
and don't go ahead and push this out to
all of you on the webinar so that you
can look at this on your own time
enterprise private cloud is something
that a lot of our customers do use in
data science applications some that are
breda went over and in greater detail
here let me go ahead and push this out
to all of you right now see are you able
to see my screen right now so I'm
showing you this cloud notebook that we
sent out earlier on in our invite and
with the help of this I want to point
out how you can actually use this to
enter our cloud platform so when you
have the link to the notebook or the
link to some of the other notebooks that
I sent out during the examples with the
tweets or the real estate example you'll
have this open in link at the bottom and
you can go in there and open it in one
of our cloud products Wolfram
one is a recommended choice if if you
are getting started with the Wolfram
system or we also have the development
platform and then programming lab and
Mathematica online so if I choose
Wolfram one you should be able to open
this notebook in in your cloud account
I am already signed in if you're not
then you will be asked to quickly create
a Wolfram ID and we do offer some free
credits for you too it's free to get
started so you can actually play around
and see how things happen and then later
on you can you know start a subscription
if you would like so that would be an
entry point to the tool from one and if
you have any questions feel free to
email us and we'll be happy to follow up
with more details on how this works and
how you can use it let's see I'm going
to just quickly take okay there is an
unrelated question about unity link I
can try and get back to you later yes we
do have unity link to connect
Mathematica to it's not related to data
science but who knows you might be able
to use that to get some sort of
interesting data in and work with it I
don't think anything in the technology
is really beyond you being capable of
being used for data science so
limitations on throttles or Twitter API
be honest I haven't really pushed it to
the limits I've only done some
expiratory analysis but if you do run
into issues please feel free to get back
to us for technical issues you can email
support at Wolfram comm or for if you
want to know more resources to learn
about things feel free to email Wolfram
you that's from - you at Wolfram comm
that's a resource for all educational
material I can also try and bring it up
here to point you and here we have our
data science and statistics catalog and
we also have machine learning if you are
interested in that and we actually also
have a machine learning series going on
but Jamie will be talking
or about and give you some pointers to
so those are good resources to learn
about stuff let's see
I very happy to see this comment from
Android saying that it's great away from
language would be great for his
exploratory analysis we hope you're able
to convince others also and really have
enjoyed working with it if there are
other phases of the pipeline you want to
use Wolfram language for for please feel
free to get back in touch with us and
Jimmy will also mention probably how you
can access the entire webinar at a later
date but I will sign off right now and
let our host complete the webinar for
today thank you thanks Sabrina thanks
very much for that presentation you've
got lots of comments coming in people
enjoyed it so thank you let me share my
screen I wanted to this is a Wolfram you
page that I'm showing it from our
machine learning topic this does
conclude today's presentations and we
hope you you did enjoy the talks and
learned about concepts and tools you can
use to unleash the power of your data an
email will be sent as a breda said to
everyone in today's audience with a link
to this recording and download links as
well for the presentations we look
forward to seeing you online again on
May 16th for the second webinar in this
data science series our topic will be
automated data science you'll receive a
reminder email about this session and I
also want to invite you to sign up for
the machine learning webinar series that
you see on your screen right now at
Wolfram you will go ahead and put that
link up in the chat this series
continues on May 9th and you can find
that signup link on our Wolfram You
pages or any of our Wolfram site our
home page I believe has a link at the
very bottom under upcoming events we
really do appreciate your feedback and
we use survey results to guide us in
making improvements in the Wolfram
technology stack and adding features
important to the user community so a
survey will pop up in your screen as you
exit today and we
value your input and comments and
feedback so thank you very much for
joining us today we'll see you next time
have a great day